but players you were trying to make it
impact right there's so much that goes
on in exhibition for the young guys it's 110%
you got to make an impact for the veterans find
your Rhythm so sometimes exhibition it's a wild
card kind of game tatara will slide it into wood
down low quick shot there and a save by wal set
back up top long drive and a kick save there by
wall stees yes saw the young defenseman let
that one fly malinsky we'll talk more about
him as the game continues on because he's got
high expectations was an absolutely fantastic
stand out at Cornell yeah and you see miles W
his first shift that line should dominate this
game by the way absolutely flatten a wild player
that's his game look for him to deliver five or
six big checks a game that puck was sent in by
the veteran Merl with a quick shot save on and
in right even if it's not with a Parry Club an
opportunity to fill out the roster in Iowa ABS
with a steel that's off escap quick shot there
Score yoel kir says how do you do I'll take it
able to rip it by the Blocker of wallad the
ABS have an early one- nothing lead Shel can
see it's a broken Play In The End Zone little
pass across the move goes right to I think that
was meant to go down low got deflected to keep
your run to watch the pass going down low off
the skate boom right up top he says thank you
Far Side posting in shade up game seven hey Mo
I don't even like to talk the wild with the
first Power Play opportunity of the game and
it's knocked ahead abs are in Pursuits set down
in front for Colton and a save by W that loose
but it goes off of wood into the [Music] corner
at far side and a one timer and that kick save
by Onan tough he couldn't get it out wild will
continue and he's still one of the few players
that can play and carry 225 lbs and be mobile Jack
Johnson's got like that for effect a little bit
it up to the point long shot there loose Puck oh
and it's underneath the wallad took a peak behind
him punch that they used to have and Milwood
definitely he's not replacing liscott but he
helps that physical forward presence the
Avalanche need so here we are for period
number two again the ABS still on the outside
on this power play chance now 40 seconds left
in it reing in quick Cent P got four and
Sammy Walker had that pot squirt right to
him able to get a little tiny one-time off past
Odin in in the Minnesota Wild with a power play
goal of tied it at one and when it did it lost
its speed so watch the puck go down goes right
under and it slows down then gets deflected in
front and Walker just jumps all over it so it's
a twice broken play watch it go down here goes
under the body slows down deflected there and
all of a sudden it's anybody's kind of a freeall
a bit of a Hungry Hippo situation while trying
to keep that momentum going as the ABS finally
get control Ken Hees it off and Weinstein cut
off at Center ice right back comes Minnesota
it's height cut off and a good sliding play by
the defenseman hunt in a centering pass the ads
broke it up Minnesota with hate with a shot and
that one off the leg right in front of Anan so
the wi sends it all the way to the near Point AAR
marching good tough angle shot off the goal stick
of [Applause] w Linsky gives it up that'ss it back
centery pass broken up by the wild as keep control
here side what timer what a club save by wall
St against the ash for sure on home
opener no doubt about it of course
Tor hold there in Chicago as well as we
underway with this third Peri off the
stick hanged away from kirant shman steers it
deep oh look say quick centering pass knocked
away shot save rebound kicked away and Coen the
veteran suppose depending on the day here's the
goal score for Minnesota Walker with a good
centering pass save by hole spread out right
P there SC a terrific pass to the near side of the
Creon Walker with his second of the contest this
one an even strength goal is put the wild up two
to one you'll see there there's a beautiful play
nice lateral movement now watch the play across
right there and it looks like there's only a pox
WID that that can slide in watch the left foot
there's the first save here's the big push and I
thought he had the post covered oh and it somehow
just barely slid in the back of the net musle his
way fre able to get there back shot deflected wide
to the ABS now starting to press the issue looking
for the tying goal down the slot deflected Ry was
chasing sandel it head up turns and shoots save
rebound score Henry mby parked himself right in
front of wallad Johnny on the spot on the rebound
with a backhand slam and we've got a two2 hockey
game when you could feel kind of started at the
end of the second and he's carried that into the
third he's had chances he's been physical wa for
the Charlotte Checkers last year had 13 goals
free agent signing by the Avalanche and you can
see he's just hungry in front he's wearing that
91 in the same spot old C used to be at score
a bunch of goals and that's a big one for the
ABS gets the energy in the building [Applause]
back
whed away K Ron a Merl back to giv R
Top of the circles with his shot and
there's a blocker Sav by walstead again molinski
delivers Ronson finding tuy just slugging
off Conor door tuy tried to wrap it around
with the back hand and good active stick
there by Johansson Far Side what a save
by wal absolutely robs Olson on the onetime
and I think Avalanche fans are really going
to enjoy watching him for the next four years
well it's not often you expect the guy to come
out and get you like that well sadly I mean d
hes probably just thinking he can cruise on the
outside say rebound score that long shot went
off of home and it's cleaned up by Minnesota
the PowerPlay goal to make it a 3-2 game is
juara I don't know if it broke holes helmet
but just a simple when to face off shot on net
look at that deflection in front H's helmet pops
off but they never blow the whistle if there's
an immediate scoring chance after so that's a
good goal as long as it's right there in the
crease they allow the play to happen if it
goes in the corner they'll blow the whistle right
away but yeah blew the Buckle off the helmet it's
off on ahead olon down the slot H shoot and the
kick save by wal oh he got that big right pat
down and a breakaway It's Sammy Walker in two on0
shot St ler short side rips it home and the wild
have put it away it's a for game with it minute
three to go here in the third period and it was a
good play so here look all four guys are down they
are looking for that goal but nobody's back now I
can't believe L ter didn't go back to Walker for
the hatrick can you believe that Mo selfish now
great shot top shelf for M Night the peanut butter
cookies but should have went back to Walker for
the hatties well maybe he said you got two can I
get one can I get one tar and wood seem to be a
okay they're out there but just 14 seconds to go
in this game no puyer score oh wall with the rare
misfire he tried to glove it it gets right by him
and Riley toughy yeah we mentioned 19 goals in the
American Hockey League last year gets deflected I
think of John Merill stick coming in we'll take a
look at it right here it might have changed the
little Direction either way it was top shelf and
I think the best player on the ice tonight it's
down Minnesota has it out of the final 5 Seconds
scores to the Avalanche and and that is going to
do it so pre-season game number one comes to an